[MUSIC PLAYING]
SACHIT MISHRA: Hi.
I'm Sachit Mishra,
and today I'm going
to show you how fast and easy it
is to build apps for the Google
Assistant using API.AI
These apps can be used
by anyone with access to
the assistant on Google
Home and eligible
mobile devices.
For this video, I'll
build an assistant app
similar to the one
used in our Facts
about Google sample
hosted on GitHub.
The Facts about
Google sample works
by telling the user facts
about either Google's history
or its headquarters,
whichever the user prefers.
But once we're
finished here, you
can go to our developer site
to build out the sample further
and insert your own facts with
whatever you know a lot about,
like cats or knitting.
Let's go to the API.AI tool,
and I'll show you the steps
to build this from scratch.
First, let's log in
to the Actions console
and click Add a Project.
We'll give it some name, and
a new project is created.
The Actions console
is the starting point
for any new assistant app.
It lets us choose our
tools for development,
gives us access to analytics
and testing utilities,
and provides the forms to
enter the directory listing
information about the app.
Here we're given the option
of either using API.AI
or the raw Actions
SDK with our own NLA,
or Natural Language
Understanding solution.
Let's choose API.AI
We're logged into API.AI,
and an agent has
been created for us.
An API.AI agent is an NLU module
for your product or service.
The term agent in API.AI
maps to an app for assistant.
So for the purpose
of this video,
consider them to mean
one and the same.
After creating the agent, we
are taken to the Intents screen.
Intents and entities
are two main concepts
important to creating
interaction scenarios
in API.AI.
Intents are entry points into
the conversation and map what
a user says to what your
conversational experience
should say or do.
There might be many
different ways for the user
to say one thing they
want, but they should all
resolve to one type of response
determined by a single intent.
A conversation will be
made up of many back
and forth turns in which each
of the user's responses maps
to an intent.
Notice that our app already
has a default fallback intent.
This will be triggered when
the user says something
that isn't recognized.
It also has a default
welcome intent.
This is the main entry
point to our conversation,
as shown by the fact that it is
triggered by the welcome event.
Let's get rid of some of
these pre-made greetings
and specify our own.
Something like, "Welcome
to Facts about Google.
Which one do you want to
hear about, Google's history
or its headquarters?"
This serves to
acknowledge the user
and separate our assistant
app from the Google Assistant,
as well as direct the
user to the next turn
in the conversation, in
this case using an either/or
question.
Remember, all your prompts
should be a reflection
of your app's persona.
This is vital to creating
a great experience.
Before I move on
to the next intent,
I'll need to create
some custom entities.
Entities are objects
that serve to enumerate
the different things
people will talk about
in their natural speech input.
You will use entities as
slot-filling parameters
required for business
logic in your intents.
In API.AI, there are two
different types of entities.
There are pre-built
system entities
to handle the most popular
common concepts, like time,
number, address,
date, et cetera.
And then there are developer
entities, which we'll use here.
I'll create developer entities
using the API.AI web console,
but you can also upload
them in JSON and CSV formats
or through API calls.
To get started,
Facts about Google
should know two
categories of facts--
history, which
might also be termed
past, and headquarters, or HQ.
Once I'm all done I'll
have something like this.
Next, I'll create an
intent for the use case
that our assistant app will
support, telling a fact.
Let's create the
intent, tell_fact, then
add a few examples of how the
user may ask to hear a fact.
We are expecting the user
to respond to the prompt
given in the welcome intent
or possibly ask us for a fact
after they've already heard
one, so they might say something
as simple as history,
or something more
complicated like, I'd
love to hear something
about Google's history.
As I'm adding new
examples, you can
see how they're
automatically annotated
with the fact category entity.
This means the user can provide
the entity value directly
in the phrase used to
trigger this intent.
We can change the annotation,
the names of parameters,
and the entities to
fit our use case.
API.AI will learn from the
annotated examples and entities
to understand more
variations of such requests.
Let's add a few more
examples of what a user might
say to trigger this intent.
"Tell me about Google's HQ."
"I want to hear about
the history of Google."
"Can you tell me about
Google's headquarters?"
"Give me a fact about Google."
Generally, you'd want to
provide about 10 to 12 samples
to train API.AI on
variations a user might say.
Notice that the last phrase does
not include the fact category
entity, indicating to API.AI
that the category won't always
be specified in the
triggering phrase.
Down here, I'll name the
action for this intent
as tell.fact, which will be the
trigger for my business logic
to get the relevant response.
As a side note, be aware
that actions on API.AI
have a different meaning
than actions on Google.
Again, we can see
how the fact category
parameter was
created automatically
from the annotated examples.
This intent has
only one parameter,
but you can imagine one that
might take a whole bunch,
like a recipe-finding
intent that
might need a list of
ingredients and dish types.
Facts about Google won't be able
to tell a fact without knowing
which category of
fact the user wants,
so I'm going to mark this
parameter as required
and add a prompt for it.
Facts about Google
will use these
prompts to request the missing
information if it was not
provided directly in the phrase
used to trigger this intent,
like if the user just said,
give me a fact about Google.
You can add more than
one of these prompts
for each parameter
to add variation.
Our prompt will be something
like, which would you
prefer to hear about, Google's
history or its headquarters?
Let's hard code a
simple fact in for now,
like Google was founded in 1998.
Now we can test out this intent
right in the API.AI simulator.
Let's try one of the
phrases we provided,
"Give me a fact about Google."
We can see that this
intent was matched,
and we get the prompt
for the fact category
parameter because it wasn't
provided in the triggering
phrase.
And after answering that, we
get the hard-coded response
given here.
But our actual response is
going to change depending
on which type of fact
that user wants to hear,
so we can't just hard code one.
In order to provide this
sort of a dynamic experience,
we'll need to add a web
hook to our API.AI agent.
This will be a
web-hosted endpoint
that API.AI can query
for a given intent
in order to provide
some response.
Your web hook will need to
be an https endpoint built
on any technology
of your choosing.
It will be responsible for
parsing the incoming API.AI
request and returning
an appropriately
formatted response.
This can be a
little complicated,
so we built a client
library in Node.js
that can be used to interface
with your business logic.
Let's take a look at how it can
be used to build a Node.js web
hook for this app.
Here we have a cloud function
that initializes the API.AI app
class imported from our
client library's npm package
and initializes it with the
incoming request response pair.
We also declare a map,
call to action map,
which matches an action string
entered in the API.AI console
to a function handler.
In this case, it maps
the tell.fact action
we wrote in the console earlier
to the tellFact function, which
will be passed to reference
to the API.AI app object.
Calling app.handleRequest
with this action map
will trigger the logic to
send a response to API.AI.
The tellFact function does a
couple of interesting things.
First, it initializes some
fact string to a default
and then uses the
app.getArgument method
to pull the value of the
fact category parameter
in the intent.
Based on that value, it
fetches some fact for the user.
Then it forms a
response for the user.
The response used is based
on the surface capabilities
of the user device.
If the device has the ability
to output visual information
on a screen, like a
phone, a rich response
is used, which includes
a simple response chat
bubble, a card with
some text, and an image
with its own alternative
text for accessibility.
Finally, the response includes
some suggestion [INAUDIBLE]
to further the conversation.
For devices which cannot
output to a screen,
a simple string is used as a
spoken response to the user.
Now that we've built our
web hook as a cloud function
and deployed to a hosting
solution like Google Cloud
functions, we'll need to
tell API.AI to use it.
To do that, go to fulfillment,
click Enabled under the Web
Hook settings, and type in
your web hook's hosted address.
Then head back to
the tellFact intent
and check Use Web
Hook at the bottom.
This will tell API.AI to
use the response provided
from your web hook instead
of one you typed here
for this intent.
Again, we can test this intent
right in the API.AI simulator,
but this time let's not use
a phrase given in our User
Says section.
Let's try, "Tell me something
interesting about Google's
past."
and immediately we get
the simple response
generated from our web hook.
This is one of the coolest
things about API.AI.
It's machine learning, trained
on the phrases we provided,
recognized the user
input even if it
didn't match the examples
verbatim, called the web hook,
and provided the response.
Pretty neat, huh?
We can also check out the JSON
request sent to our web hook
here.
Normally it'd be a little
hard to parse this,
but our client
library made it easy.
We can also check out the
training section of the API.AI
console to see what input has
matched against our intents,
and we can even make
live corrections
to the intents and entities
being matched right
on the spot.
We've got something
that works well here,
but we'd like to round out this
conversation just a little bit
more.
For instance, the user
might be confused as
to what they can achieve
with this assistant app.
So let's create a help
content that accepts phrases,
like "What can you
do," or "I need help."
Again, remember to provide
more examples than I am here.
We can provide some
simple help response
to try to direct the user
to our tellFact intent.
"I can tell you all
about Google's history
or its headquarters.
Which would you prefer?"
An even better
option here might be
to just provide a
fact to the user
to give them some foothold
into the conversation.
I encourage you to
try that on your own.
Finally, let's add one
more intent called quit,
which will let the user
leave the conversation.
To trigger this intent,
the user might say,
"I'm done now," or "Bye."
And we can provide a
polite response, like "OK,
see you next time."
Or, even better, if we really
want our users to come back,
we could say something
like "Come back tomorrow
for a new fact.
See you next time."
And have our web hook provide
a different fact each day.
We'll check End
Conversation at the bottom
to tell API.AI the
conversation ends here.
Now that we've got something
that works pretty well,
let's try this out in the
actions on Google web simulator
so we can see how
this experience would
work with the Google Assistant
in both a visual and voice
context.
First I'll head to
the Integrations page
and click into the Actions
on Google settings.
Then I'll click Test to
prepare my app for testing.
I can jump over to the
Actions on Google console
to test it out.
First, I'll invoke it with
"Talk to my test app."
Then I'll try a simple phrase,
like "History, please."
Before triggering
the next intent,
let's change the
simulated device to phone
and then say, "Tell me about
Google's headquarters."
It worked.
We got a rich, visual
response because we
were on a screen-based surface.
In the case that
it doesn't work,
I can check out the
debug information
given on the right side to
see the data transferring
between the assistant
server and my API.AI agent.
Now, before I submit,
I'd want to build out
this experience a little
further to provide a better user
experience and more content.
You can find out
how to do all this
in the fuller Facts about Google
sample at our developer's site.
Once we do all that, we
can head back to API.AI
and click Update.
This will tell the
actions console to update
the app with what I have here.
Now I can provide
some information
about our app and the console.
I'll give it a display
name of Facts about Google.
This will be the name
shown in the directory.
You will need to
make sure to give
your app a unique
invocation name that
follows the naming policies
published in our documentation.
I can use the microphone to
help the console determine
the pronunciation by saying,
Facts about Google allowed."
Here I can give the app an
introduction, choose its voice,
and provide a
description, which is
clear about what the app does.
After that, I'll provide
some sample invocations.
Our docs cover
the different ways
to invoke your app other than
the typical one shown here,
but I have no other invocations
so I'll just keep the default.
If you add others, make
sure you test them.
Our reviewers will tell us
that they actually work.
Next, I'll provide a couple of
images, some optional testing
instructions, and provide
my email and a link
to my privacy policy.
Once we've got all this filled
out, we'll head back to the top
and hit Save.
Normally, I determine my apps
required surface capabilities
here, but mine will
work with all devices,
so we can leave the default.
Now that that's all done,
I can click Submit.
The app is submitted, and now
I can monitor the submission
status here.
At this point, your app will
enter our review process
and, if accepted, will be
deployed to assistant devices
everywhere.
Once it's been approved, the
app is made available to anyone
using the Google
Assistant on Google Home
and other eligible devices.
Remember, you can always
test before approval
with your own device, as long as
it is linked to your developer
account.
Let's try it now.
OK, Google.
Talk to my test app.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure,
here is the test version
of my test app.
Welcome to facts about Google.
Which one do you want to
hear about, Google's history
or its headquarters?
SACHIT MISHRA: Let's
hear a headquarters fact.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Here's a fact for you.
Google has over 15 cafeterias
on its main campus.
Which one do you want
to hear about next,
Google's history
or headquarters?
Here's a fact for you.
Google released the first
version of Android in 2008.
Which one do you want
to hear about next,
Google's history
or headquarters?
SACHIT MISHRA: I'm done now.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Come back
tomorrow for a new fact.
See you next time.
SACHIT MISHRA: So that
is a really quick demo
of some of the powerful features
available in the actions
console and API.AI
developer tool.
You can find out more about
Actions on Google by checking
out the console or
reading the documentation
at
developers.google.com/actions.
That's where you can find
the more complete Facts
about Google sample
and walkthrough,
as well as the number
geni sample, which
is a great reference for
design best practices.
We also have an Actions on
Google G+ community so you can
ask your questions and share
your ideas with everyone.
I'm Sachit Mishra.
Thanks for watching.
I look forward to
seeing what you build.
[MUSIC PLAYING]